the world still reeling after the death
of Alan Thicke et learned it happened
while playing ice hockey with his son
Carter and only et is with the man who
made the 911 call mr. Matthew said now I
understand that you were the one who
made the 9-1-1 call today can you just
walk me through what exactly happens how
you got that news and how you ended up
making the call to 9-1-1 i was sitting
at my desk and three guys came through
the door about 15 minutes after the
hunting started and were saying we got a
guy down please call 9-1-1 call 9-1-1
darren that's what we did and did you
know at first that it was Alan Thicke at
what point did you realize that it was
Alan no I had no idea was Alan we were
told I was told that it was a guy down
because now out there everybody's just a
player all team members I actually
didn't know was al until the EMTs got
here and we sat him up because he was he
was on his back but he was breathing and
talking I didn't hear him but you could
see that there was movement cuz all the
players were around him at that time
when they sat him up was he speaking was
he coherent what was happening yeah it
was very coherent in fact he had Carter
take a picture of him he said hey kid
take a picture of me make sure you get
the rink in the background as they were
taking him out of here so yeah and when
he went by us he gave us the thumbs-up
like doing good guys I'm good I think
that's part of what's so hard to hear
about it is that his son was here with
him and they frequented this rink right
I mean you knew him you were friends
with him absolutely Alan was a great guy
he always checked in with everybody a
neat way
he was just a just a super guy just like
anybody but the family was always here
is brother Todd skated with the savory
Carter of course being here with them
and I felt bad for Carter I could see he
was very shaken out by the whole thing I
don't know we just saw something came
across the news that they think he's
passed away so we were very saddened
because we just didn't think that was
going to be the case because he didn't
leave here like that
[Music]